this is a story about angry people it's
about live-streaming and it's about how
nothing seems to have changed because
what I wanted to do this year was I
wanted to try and predict the future I
know Ian you've said right at the start
we need empathy not prediction but I
wanted to also take a pattern I wanted
to look at what was in 2010 when we had
the last general election I want to draw
a line from that to where we are here
and then I want to work out what the
2020 general election was going to be
like but I came across a massive problem
I wanted to leave you with a view of the
future vaguely optimistic note to end
the conference song but what the hell
has changed in the last five years
because I've always said that prediction
for the future never turn out to be true
neither the best you can do is kind of
extrapolate hope that nothing
world-changing comes along because 15
years ago I would have said that you
know everyone is going to have a really
powerful desktop computer at home to
change the world I wouldn't have
predicted the Palm Pilot that actually
came out of my pocket but as far as the
web as far as most everyday tech goes as
far as what we're talking about here
2015 was the same as 2010 I mean look at
the general election look at this that's
2010 I mean sure we now have a few more
people engaged online we now have a few
more politicians with Twitter accounts
but it's basically the bloody same
smartphones in 2010 they were already
mainstream we had the iPhone 4 we had
half decent versions of Android we
already had Facebook and Twitter we'd
had them for years every high-profile
thing to do with our world on the web
since then has been an iteration on that
oh look you've got a shiny screen and
it's curved at the edges oh look you've
got another social network that's
another front-end to a database I was
making this is me five years ago I was
making predictions in 2010 about flash
mobs about social change about the
accelerating speed of society and now
that all just seems normal it's happened
it's been four years four years since
our now departed Ed Balls tweeted Ed
Balls
for years and that's still a punchline
you're still laughing at it for anyone
who wants the future to be here now this
is a really frustrating time so I am
left wondering what's next what is the
culture of 2020 going to look like if it
is just a faster version of 2015 faster
though faster is the really important
word because that is one thing that has
changed in the last five years the speed
a lot of people have seen this last
month we have memories pizza they said
in a TV interview that they would choose
not to cater a gay wedding under the new
laws that were coming in in their state
um the in first wave of backlash of
course hit immediately as that video
went viral and the owners well depending
on depending on who was right in the
article the owners either were forced to
close down their shop or chose to close
down their shop depending on who you
were listening to and they went into
hiding but then then a second wave of
backlash hits just as fast as the first
as conservative Christians arrive to
fight the terrible oppression and they
donate $800,000 to the pizza shop in a
few days dies their terrifyingly fast
over reaction from both sides both
immediately polarize sides far more that
I'd ever thought possible and did you
rember sure gate everyone yeah I heard
ad in the audience because that was a
controversy that had the kind of air of
inevitability about it from the start
from the first comments that maybe just
just maybe a shirt covered in pictures
of Stan scantily clad women isn't really
suitable for any workplace after the
1970s let alone a major scientific press
conference from those first reasonable
comments I think everyone involved had
that own freely we know how this is
going to play out because within a
couple of hours it's not so much a
debate as a ritual shouting match
between two immediately polarized sides
both shouting storm and arguments in
each other and not wanting to back down
in case the other side thinks they've
won and meanwhile article after article
post after post tweet after tweet write
an inflammatory headline stick an image
and the tweet so it's bigger in
everyone's timeline get the numbers in
what a newsroom for 18 months I've
scene the requirements for numbers
because that's how you get them you you
you go for the clickbait you you try to
be extreme because if you're not extreme
enough then your own side will start
criticizing you and thinking you're
going to be a traitor for the other side
trying to subtly support the others that
wasn't happening in 2010 not with that
speed
not with that viciousness not with
everyone getting in on it small
communities sure but the whole web not
so much that speed of outrage isn't ever
going to slow down now so hold that
thought because this year we have two
competing live video apps we had
periscope we have meerkat mayor cat came
along first use Twitter Twitter launched
periscope a couple of weeks later and
basically shut down meerkat and kill
their access because that's how we work
now um neither of those were ever going
to become mainstream truly mainstream
because the technology isn't quite there
yet
they are basically Friendster Dermer
Friendster was like Facebook only a
little bit too early it was good but it
wasn't Facebook the world wasn't quite
ready for it they are the Palm Pilot I
had one of those it was good it was good
but it wasn't the iPod it wasn't iPhone
it was a little bit too early periscope
and meerkat are unlike the Palm Pilot
they are great early versions and we
currently have yet so just after
periscope launched our me and a friend
were in the middle of London starved a
stream out of nowhere and said right
okay let's let's guide people around
London 200 300 400 people right now 50
you know that Cove a startup has writ
goes why everyone's good a year oh ah
yes that's what's happen that works for
a bit shaky because it's not quite been
figured out they are Friendster they are
the Palm Pilot the world isn't quite
prepared but someone is going to crack
live video streaming might be five years
might be 10 my pet theory is still that
Apple is going to put little cameras in
their earbuds because they've got the
cable you've got the battery but that's
not required people people are now used
to folks just holding up a camera like
this that's normal where you wave to the
Internet people wait for hey there we go
the Internet has made no comment waving
back at you because they're rude
come on oh no hello hello thank you
they're two dirt Wittig whoever you are
um that's not going about go mainstream
not yet but when it does when someone
cracks that it's going to have the same
step change of Hector's Twitter because
the world is going to no not in the kind
of shonky five minutes ago real time
we've got now they are going to know in
real time to the second what's happening
and that's important because why didn't
you do this is going to become why don't
you do this because that means we've got
proper ubiquitous surveillance Sky News
is already more than happy to go live to
someone with a webcam if they need to
that's in Anbar province they need to go
to an interview there damn the picture
quality they'll get the interview there
first it doesn't matter
soon as live-streaming actually starts
to happen they will have an amateur
reporter on the ground anywhere whenever
something happens not when it's happened
when it is happening but that also means
that if an online mob of 2020 targets
you then there is suddenly a chance that
you are being watched and broadcasted
live whenever you're in public as an
organized anonymous angry mob comes
through every nearby geotag live stream
looking for you as that seems improbable
if it seems that no one would go to so
great an effort for so small a reward
remember that over the last year there
were threats of bombs and mass shooting
sent credible threats because of
criticism of video games multiple times
if people are angry about something so
trivial what do they do when they
actually care because there are reasons
to care there is another side at that
point there is Baltimore there is
Ferguson so astonishing tweet isn't it
because it used to be but the narrative
or anything like that was set by press
releases by edited interviews by news
organizations by pundits arguing the
political views of whoever controlled
the tabloids in the television
increasingly it's controlled by flow to
filter bubbles that's where we are now
by the hot Tate's of 2015 journalism by
by the
perhaps loom easy share and by the
clickbait it's like they took BuzzFeed
and just turned it wrong it's horrible
the footage that you see today is
limited by what people choose to send if
the photo you take on the ground isn't
actually flattering to your side maybe
you won't share it but if it paints you
in a positive light then yes of course
you will
but with live-streaming that the people
watching these people just here they are
seeing exactly what you see in real-time
the vast majority of the world will
still see afterwards of course but that
won't change the fact that sooner or
later there is gone young to speak etus
with me sooner or later there is going
to be an event where thousands of people
tens of thousands of people when more
than in this room
thousands of thousand does it will
believe that they were there because
they saw it through the eyes of someone
who is holding their camera up and
that's a big difference it won't be
where were you when you found out that X
happened it will be were you watching
when it did and that means that suddenly
you don't have one eye witness you don't
have two eyewitnesses in one bit of film
that can be changed afterwards and
editing tweeted endlessly torn apart by
pundits you have 10,000 eye witnesses
who all saw the same thing so when that
moment happens let's put these two
things together when that moment happens
when the word on a live stream trips for
a news anchors mouth as easy as tweeted
does today when you start seeing
whatever company actually wins and it
ain't the drew Paris couple and whatever
company actually wins when their name
starts being dropped into conversation
like tweeted is today remember when it
felt like nothing was changing remember
all complaining it is just new shiny
screens because things are changing this
because sometimes it's not about
spectacle it's not about the big thing
that's going to make everyone go well
sometimes it is about slow change it is
about changing people's opinions it is
about reaching the future through slow
incremental steps and things getting a
little bit better day after day after
day
so all I can say is enjoy the next five
years my name is Tom Scott enjoy the
after-party good night thank you
okay folks Wow well that is it believe
it or not we are